so we have a polynomial here and what
i'm curious about is what is the
remainder if i were to divide this
polynomial by
let's just say
x
minus
if i were to divide it if i were to if i
i want the remainder if i want the
remainder when i divide this polynomial
by x minus 2.
and you could do this you could figure
this out with algebraic long division
but i'll give you a hint it is much
simpler and much less computational
intensive and takes much less space on
your paper if you use the polynomial
remainder theorem and if that's
unfamiliar to you there's other videos
that actually cover that so why don't
you have a go at it
all right so now let's let's let's work
through this together the polynomial
remainder theorem tells us that the
remainder if when i take a polynomial if
i take a polynomial
if i take a polynomial p of x and if i
were to divide it by
if i were to divide it by an x minus a
the remainder
the remainder of that is just going to
be equal to p of a
is just going to be equal to p
of
p of a so in this case our p of x is
this
what is our a well our a is going to be
positive 2. remember it's x minus a
so let me do this
our a
is equal to positive 2. so to figure out
the remainder we just have to evaluate p
of 2. so let's do that
so the remainder
the remainder in this case is going to
be equal to
p
of 2
p of 2 which is equal to
so let's see it's going to be i'll just
do it all in magenta negative 3 times 8
minus
let's see minus 4 times 4 is 4 times 4
plus 20
minus 7.
so let's see this is
negative 24
minus 16
plus 20
minus 7
and so that gives us let's see negative
24 minus 16 this is negative 40.
all right i'm just going to step by step
this is equal to negative
actually i can do this in my head all
right here we go so this is negative 40
plus 20 is negative 20 minus 7 is
negative 27
negative
27.
and that was pretty neat because if we
did it if we did if we tried if we
attempted to do this without the
polynomial remainder theorem we would
have had to do
a bunch of algebraic long division now
if we did the algebraic long division we
would have gotten the quotient and all
of that but we don't need we don't need
the quotient we don't need to know so if
we did all the algebraic long division
you know we would have taken our p of x
and then we would have divided the x
minus a into it
x minus a into it and we would have
gotten
we would have gotten
a quotient here
q of x and we would have done all this
business down here all this algebraic
long division probably wouldn't have
even fit on the page but eventually we
would have gotten to a point where we
got an expression that has a lower
degree than this it would have to be a
constant because this is a first degree
so it'd have to be essentially zero
degree
so we would eventually gotten to our
negative 27 but this was much much much
much easier than having to go through
this entire exercise hopefully you
appreciated that